si on reprend les éléments empirique
tels qu'on les connaît je pense par
exemple la dernière enquête de l'inserm
et peacock et une enquête
épidémiologique sur l'épidémie à travail
classes sociales ce qu'on constate un
ace que ce qui est écrit noir sur blanc
dans les résultats de cette enquête
c'est que au début de l'épidémie et
d'ailleurs ça a été le cas plus ou moins
tout le long les 10% les plus riches ont
été les plus contaminant se sont pas
ceux qui sont le plus morts de
l'épidémie puisque ce sont ceux qui ont
la meilleure santé est aussi le meilleur
accès aux soins par contre ce sont eux
qui ont le plus diffusé
qui ont été les plus touchées par le
virus et donc qui ont été les plus
contaminés
sait on nous l'a suffisamment dit si
vous faites contaminé pas vous êtes
aussi contaminants donc ça c'est une
réalité empirique
alors à quoi c'est dû pas uniquement en
résidence secondaire évidemment et aux
parisiens qui descendent en province
profiter de l'air et de la nature ce qui
me semble par ailleurs être une
revendication aussi légitime
non par contre il est vrai qu'il ya un
mode de vie un mode de vie bourgeois
notamment le voyage par exemple voyage
international qui est quelque chose qui
est pas du tout réparti équitablement
dans la population qui est vecteur de
diffusion du virus
il y a aussi et ça c'est écrit aussi
dans l'étude des pick up à un mode de
vie basé sur la sociabilité dont on
parlait tout à l'heure un quand vous
êtes plus vous être hirsch en france
plus vous avez de relations sociales
c'est triste mais c'est une réalité et
plus vous êtes pauvres - vous en avez
donc finalement c'est une réalité se
fait là et puis sur la les résidences
secondaires donc cette réalité empirique
et sur les résistants secondaire va
écouter c'est vrai que la société est
injuste parce qu'on est dans une société
de classe ces différences de classes ne
sont basées sur aucune chose réellement
justin ne mérite ni la compétence de mon
point de vue et les gens leur semble de
plus en plus et de plus en plus fort
vous l'avez dit vous-même depuis 2008
parce que la cape à l'accaparement des
richesses et de plus en plus grands
c'est une réalité vécue et il ya un
phénomène de paupérisation de la
population française c'est aussi une
réalité depuis 2008
[Musique]